Once you're into the mall proper, the disorientation techniques kick in.
The most obvious things to look out for are: Number one, there are no clocks in here.
Number two, you rarely ever see the outside world clearly from the inside.
They're both classic methods for skewing your perception of time.
Next, the lighting and color schemes are both harsh and bright,...
...the floor is tiled and reflective, which also means it's loud in here...
...with that muzak and people talking and kids yelling.
All of the designs make you yearn for the relative comfort of a store.
You probably turn right as soon as you enter 'cause that's what most people do.
In fact, so many of us do it they actually call it the invariant right.
That's why all the bargain bins, specials, and recommended books and DVDs are always here.
It's much nicer in here.
The lighting is calmer, the music is quieter, the carpet is soft like a baby zebra.
It all makes you feel just a little bit more open...
...to the idea of spending three grand on a flat-screen TV.